we have jackson uh in new york city good
afternoon jackson how can christy and i
help
good afternoon guys how are you good
what's up
hi um so i
do football card selling on ebay and i
know i found young on 13.
oh awesome yeah so
i'm about to acquire five thousand
dollars due to
um parts that i'm currently shipping out
and i was wondering what i should do
with that money
jackson this is so cool this is this is
the probably the best call all day
i like this thank you all right so talk
to me man
um five thousand dollars what you're
going to get here pretty soon because
you're working hard you're making some
money so that's great
um what do you see where do you see
yourself going in the future do you see
yourself going to college or not going
to college
my parents want me to but i don't know i
i probably will end up going but i don't
want to
i mean i i already invested in the stock
market
um and i've been thinking about um going
into real estate investing
okay and um also
um investing in like companies like
um
like eventually like venture capitalism
okay
jackson i am loving this i'm loving it
too i'm loving it too real quick then
i'll let kristen come in here and give
you some wisdom man because she's the
she's the queen of uh starting
businesses and stuff like that
i um i want to advise you to
listen to your parents wisdom as far as
in school
okay i'm not saying that you have to go
to school but what i am saying is listen
to your parents
wisdom and guidance so this five
thousand dollars that you have
i would not invest it what i would do is
i would save it i would put it into a
savings account
keep making money keep putting money in
that account so this way
if you and your parents key word there
you
and your parents decide that college is
the best route
you can come to the table and say mom
dad hey i have 15 000
now that can go towards my college
experience
then let's say um you decide to go to
real estate school you and your parents
then you can spend that money to pay for
real estate school and then
invest the rest you know so what i would
say is i wouldn't worry about making
more money right now
i would park this money in a savings
account until you can figure out
what you are going to do you're 13 years
old i'm pretty sure
you're not driving i can put like a you
know a million dollars on it right now
you're not driving yet
and so you may need to use this money to
purchase a car
and so what i always recommend young
people is don't think about how you can
make
a lot of money fast right now no how can
you set yourself up to win
and be successful in the season you're
in right now
you're 13. you still have a new card
coming that you're going to want to
purchase
here soon you have prom coming up you're
going to want to go to
and you have college those are the three
big things that in your age bracket
you have coming up and i want you to
actually take some ownership in some of
that
if you purchase the first card say mom
dad i'll put twenty five hundred dollars
in if you all can put twenty five
hundred dollars in
that would speak volumes and you'll be
driving a car that you actually helped
purchase
and you'll be a ball it in in the young
people's uh
words i love it the one thing i would
encourage
you jackson is uh there are very few
people
in life that know what they want to do
for the rest of their life at a young
age now you have them you have those
people that oh i remember being six
years old and i wanted to
you know be an artist and then they
become an artist that's the
exception not the rule the vast majority
of people change their mind about what
they want to do about
15 times i have i never in a million
years
imagined that i would be doing what i'm
doing and i love what i'm doing so much
more than even the dreams that i had
when i was young and the reason i say
that jackson is because you're going to
figure out what you want to do
with your life with your money with your
job with your college with your time
with your career by trying stuff that's
how you're going to figure it out
you're not just going to have this
perfect plan most likely you're going to
figure it out by experimenting and what
i love about you jackson is you're
already doing that
you're selling football cards right now
you're making some money you've got some
options you might try
a different business when you're 15 that
involves you driving
maybe it's something else entirely but
you're going to figure out what you love
and what you want to do more of by
trying some stuff and because you're
trying so early and you're experimenting
and you're starting to benefit
the rewards of your hard work um even
financially
you're going to figure that out a lot
sooner and because of that you're going
to have a lot more fun and make a lot
more money but i just want to encourage
you to give yourself permission
to try some stuff and you're going to
have this in your savings account and
you're going to keep trying little
uh you know side gigs or turn those into
small businesses even before you get
college age
and you're going to know a lot more by
the end so don't feel the pressure to
have it all figured out
but keep doing what you're doing you're
doing awesome absolutely jackson stay on
the line i'm having kelly
kelly's going to send you a copy of my
teen entrepreneur toolbox kit you're
already killing it right now
about i wanna help you make a lot of
money during this season and so i'm
gonna send you this kit on me and on
christy
so you can learn how to expand your
business and make you know another 10
15 000 uh this year